los demócratas se van a enfocar en
concluir sus argumentos mostrando la
falta de acción la falta de
remordimiento por parte del ex
presidente de donald trump tras los
ataques del 6 de enero acá al capitolio
van a mostrar también el daño que ha
causado no solamente a las instalaciones
del capitolio sino también el daño
físico y mental a las personas que
trabajaban acá y a la gente que hacía
parte del legislativo incluyendo pues
congresistas y senadores de su propio
partido del partido republicano se se ha
dicho que no van a tomar se las 8 horas
que tienen hoy tienen también 8 horas
ayer presentaron sus argumentos 8 horas
los los managers demócratas que están
acusando a donald trump insurrección y
de juicio político no se van a tomar
estas ocho horas por otro lado hay una
noticia que acaba de conocer también es
que nancy pelosi a estos guardias y a
esta policía del capitolio que estaba
presente el 6 de enero
no va a ofrecer medallas de oro del
congreso por su coraje por su bravura
para defender las instalaciones y la
democracia estadounidense
bien y por otro lado cristóbal que se
espera de la respuesta de los abogados
de donald trump
todo de un otro han sido bastante
criticados bruce castro y david show en
que presentaron un inicio lo que iba a
ser su argumentación el primer día de
limpito en cuando se aprobó el caso se
dijo que era constitucional en este caso
de impeachment pues ahí de alguna manera
esa exposición que hicieron fue bastante
criticada no solamente por republicanos
sino por el propio expresidente donald
trump pero se espera entonces que hagan
una expansión de los argumentos que
presentaron ese día es decir van a
seguir argumentando porque no es
constitucional el impeachment hacia el
donald trump porque van a seguir
diciendo que el ex presidente no está en
la casa blanca por ende destituirlo pues
no se puede y el segundo caso que harán
hoy si tienen tiempo después de que
concluyan los demócratas si es que
concluyen hoy es que las palabras de
trump al criticar las elecciones al
llamar a fraude a pedir que se parara el
conteo a desconocer los votos
electorales no tienen nada que ver
con la violencia del 6 de enero en el
capitolio es decir ellos quieren
argumentar que no hay vínculo entre las
palabras de donald trump y los activos
pero lentos de sus simpatizantes que es
exactamente lo opuesto que están
argumentando los demócratas